no thanks from politics to pop parody
has long been a form of entertainment
way getting back together mashup sand
pastiches are all the rage as a means of
poking fun commentating and criticizing
skies referendum mashups were devised by
Swede mason along with skies creatives
and the process is steeped in secrecy
hence the disguise a lot of time it's
been watching it's a bit like fishing
he's sitting there for hours and hours
waiting to catch them and then you catch
it it's like it you catch the sample and
you know it makes it all worth it and
then you got put it all together so yeah
it takes you it took a while and what is
it that you're looking for what's the
secret of a good mashup I look for I'm
looking for hooks or a bit of rhythm
accidental rhythm bit of alliteration
anything till now how deed has been
restricted by law and it's only illegal
if the copyright holder of the material
gives their gifts their gives their
consent or the amount of material taken
isn't substantial
newport state of mind was viewed
millions of times until emi records
opposed it and the video was taken down
by youtube now a change in the law is
set to put the power in the hands of the
parody the test case has been in belgium
where cult cartoon characters were used
to make a point about immigration
prompting the European courts to set out
the requirements for parody they need to
have noticeable differences between what
they've created and the original work
that they've copied from so that's kind
of the first thing what are noticeable
differences bit of a potential gray area
there and secondly the court made it
explicit that the priority has to be
humorous now it's going to be up to the
judges and the national courts to decide
so with judges required to rule on humor
we could see courtroom drama turn to
courtroom fast lisa casa Sky News